[Music]
while you're watching the press preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive in the next half
hour we'll see what's making the
headlines with the financial times this
whitehall editor sebastian payne and the
daily telegraphs chief political
correspondent camilla turner so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
no real prizes for guessing then the
metro leads
on that england victory the first win
since the men in 1966 with the headline
no more years of hurt
the sun has gone for a double page
spread captioned move over fellas it's
home
also the lead story in the mail which
says it wasn't a dream we did beat
germany in a final
the guardian calls the england women's
team game changes after their historic
win at wembley
and away from football the
telegraph says that rishi sunak has
promised to bring in the biggest income
tax cut for 30 years and the financial
times reports that some european
governments have eased efforts to curb
trade in russian oil because of concerns
about inflation and just to let you know
by scanning the qr code you'll see on
the screen during the program you can
check out the front pages of those
papers while you watch us analyzing them
and as i say we're joined by sebastian
payne and camilla turner so let's dive
straight in and
i pretty much know what you were doing
earlier in the evening and uh so camilla
no more years of hurts in the metro uh
well that clever use of yeah what was it
was 30 years of hurt originally in the
song wasn't it
uh yes that's right this um football
victory we've had is completely
dominating the front pages for tomorrow
and rightly so from the tabloids to the
broadsheets it's what everyone's wanting
to to really trumpet on their front page
um i think it's a fantastic result and i
think the queen's tributes talking about
how this is really going to be an
inspiration to younger girls and women
across the country i think that's such
an important point because it's not just
this moment of national triumph and
victory for the women's team but it's
also what it signifies in a broader
sense about really elevating women's
football to a
a sort of higher level and serving as
that inspiration for the younger
generation
and sebastian i mean it is lots of
discussion now about that legacy and if
we want to get more young people
particularly girls involved in sport
well football is one of the best ways of
doing it
absolutely and look i'm not going to
confess to be a specialist in this
particular area but i also watched the
match this evening and it was just
incredible drama and great game and i
don't want to give any professional
analysis on how good it was compared to
the football but as a pure punter i
absolutely loved it and for this
snobbish snidey people who are still
saying stupid things on social media
about this then i think this needs to
take a look at themselves and look at
what an amazing triumph this is but it
is a reminder about the access that is
there's just simply not there
particularly at school levels you know i
think back to my own school days we were
still very much gender segregated into
boys do football girls do netball and i
think the inspiration we've seen from
the lionesses is an example that should
be taken to the whole country and
without presaging the next way we're
going to talk about i was very amused to
see a press notice dropped from richie
sunak's came um campaign one minute
after the result came through promising
greater access and for women for goes to
football if he wins the toy leadership
campaign so i imagine we'll see
something similar from liz trust too
because obviously everyone looks at this
and as camilla was just saying it
becomes a big unifying national moment
and just such a great triumph and good
to have some unadulterated good news
that everyone can celebrate for once
interesting about those tweets then
pre-written and uh the finger poised for
the final whistle um so camilla let's
have me staying on the theme we've got
to haven't we why not the daily mail and
the team that was beaten well it wasn't
a dream we did beat germany in a final
and of course all those references back
to 1966 that's what the men did but um
you know germany were were the favorites
i suppose given their pedigree
yes that's right and i mean again i'm
not uh i'm not going to profess to be an
expert in football but everyone knows
that germany are constantly winning
these major titles they're known to be
this incredibly strong team and probably
were the favorites to win just looking
at their track record so i think it's
all the more impressive that the english
women's team have managed to completely
overturn that and
for what is a very big moment in our
national footballing history um won this
really major title first time in over
half a century that we've won something
this big and all the more fantastic that
it's the women's team um doing it for us
so i think it's been the whole way
through this um euros tournament there's
been so much energy and so much
enthusiasm around the women's game it's
amazing that it was played on home tuff
and that um the crowds were all out
supporting them and it emerged to be
this fantastic victory let's discuss
played on home turf as you say um and
you know there's uh well i suppose two
big songs that surround these
international tournaments now football's
coming home and sweet caroline a bit of
vindaloo thrown in there i'm sure that's
your favorite one sebastian um the sun
move over fellas it's home and that
actually does particularly the
international footballing authorities
doesn't it uefa and fifa i mean some
fifa officials have said that's one
reason why we're a bit hesitant in
giving you uh the next men's world cup
because you assume that it's your game
oh well look i mean like it's three
lines is such a great song so i remember
from my childhood in 1996 so when we had
obviously the tournament a couple of
years ago when it was again totally
ubiquitous across everywhere in the
country it's a parody song it's not
about a triumphant xenophobic expression
it's simply mocking the fact that so
much national energy and effort is put
into our sporting prowess and when you
listen to the lyrics of three lines
which again are very witty and funny
they get to this exact point so i i
think there are some po faces who don't
quite understand the mood it's taken in
but uh as i said i think it is just such
a good moment what i'd much rather see
from the premier league and from the
from the fa is um getting
female football on parity with male
football because it's obviously
something they've not taken seriously
for many years and i think if you look
at the outpouring of happiness to this
but going back to what i said earlier
about what most people would see as the
sheer quality of the game then it's
something that is long long overdue and
one thing i was struck by as well if you
think back to when we had those the the
you the euro performances a couple of
years ago some of the scenes at wembley
stadium were really quite appalling and
there was a lot of criticism of the
police for people for sort of quite
yobish behavior but i think actually
it's been a very very different
atmosphere and i've spoken to friends
who've been at wembley stadium tonight
and again i think that's very much part
of how you can improve the game by
making sure men and females football are
finally seen on an equal level
absolutely very different on the pitch
as well uh much less simulation and uh
rolling around like you've been shot by
a sniper when you've hardly been touched
but let's move on uh let's get on
camilla to your paper uh and that
leadership contest that uh sebastian was
mentioning there and you've got the
telegraph's got uh zahavi nadeem zahavi
the chancellor comes off the fence to
give booster trusts his backing so
that's another big scout for the trust
campaign
yes that's right and it's been a pretty
big few days in terms of high profile
backers coming out for liz trust because
we've also had ben wallace and tom tugan
hat so this is um now three quite big
names in close succession all coming out
for liz trust and nadeem dahawi had
previously said as soon as he was
knocked out of the leadership contest he
said i won't be commenting father but
clearly he has broken his silence to
come out for his trust and he explains
the reason why saying that he prefers
her booster economic approach compared
to the rishi sunak doomster attitude so
he's really getting behind the liz trust
economic vision of tax cuts
and that will encourage growth saying
this is the the right way to do it and i
suppose given that he is the the current
chancellor that does lend some weight in
to her argument of course there are
other former leadership contenders who
are behind rishi sunap we've got um
jeremy hunt and greg hans both behind
him so it's not to say all the former
leadership contestants have come out for
liz trust but certainly in the past few
days we've seen these these different
big names and it really shows there's a
bit of a momentum gathering behind her
and clearly a feeling in some quarters
of the conservative party that um at
this stage in the race she's really
looking like the favorite to win oh okay
uh listen we're pretty much out of time
for for this section we'll be getting
sebastian's thoughts on that and other
dimensions of the leadership contest in
a moment or two and uh coming up after
the break we've got this in the
financial times the west eases
russian oil curves as inflation and
energy risks mount
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview right here on sky news with me
now are the white hall editor with the
financial times sebastian payne and
chief political correspondent at the
daily telegraph camilla turner right
let's continue with financial time
sebastian
the west eases russian oil curves as
inflation and energy risks mount to just
tell us how that's easing and you know
what it tells us about the resolve to
make russia feel financial pain
well when this whole crisis began the
response from from all eu members and
across the west was very strong and the
simple reason was that they saw a clear
dividing line about this the simple fact
that you know obviously russia had
invaded ukraine and should be punished
but obviously a good sort of almost six
months into that since that invasion and
the economic consequences that are
becoming very real you know we were
talking before the break about the tour
leadership contest and so much that is
dominated by the economy and that's
because inflation is high and it's
getting pretty set in for a long period
of time and so you're starting to see
these tensions emerge from several
european countries about what you should
do about this to try and ease it for
ordinary people and the story we have on
the front of the ft tomorrow is the eu
is looking at amending some of the
restrictions on the insurance of ships
which again were introduced to make life
harder for russia to try and help oil
exports around the globe and that's
again this big concern about energy
supplies there was a moment last week in
the uk where we almost had blackouts in
part of london because there wasn't
enough energy and the uk had to pay
astronomical prices to buy electricity
through the interconnected that goes to
europe and that might all sound quite
complex but the fact is the energy
crisis is real it's about to get a lot
worse and western governments are going
to face more difficult challenges about
how tough and how sustained you want to
be on russia when you're facing these
problems at home and so far the west has
been entirely united on this eventually
the uk being at the forefront in terms
of sanctions but there are but i think
that will start a more dividing line as
we get into the winter and the energy
crisis becomes more acute just just
briefly on that sebastian on the uk at
the forefront of sanctions also in this
article is a very interesting line here
from an underwriting director at lloyd's
market association saying there is no
current uk ban affecting global
shipments of russian oil and the uk is
of course the centre of the maritime
insurance industry
and again there's been discussions about
that kind of ban for some period of time
pretty much since the war began but as i
said that comes with very high economic
consequences and the west is trying to
isolate russia as much as possible and
that's obviously led to us in this big
rise in energy prices and the big
rise of inflation across the world there
so i think there is this difficult
balance and i think whoever's the next
prime minister will have to face more
and more of these questions later this
year okay camilla let's stay with
ukraine and uh the russians as we've
just been discussing there uh
weaponizing so to speak energy also
weaponizing food supplies and this on
the telegraph in the business section
little piece on the front page as well
ukraine crop likely to halve
warns president zielinski i mean that
really is worrying
yes exactly this is um
a very clear example of the broader
impact of the war in ukraine really
rippling out throughout the rest of the
world with this latest warning from
zolensky um because if ukraine's um food
output um its exports have that it
causes really serious problems for for
other countries particularly african
nations and developing countries that
really rely on um
these ukrainian crops it's known as the
bread basket of europe because it has
such a huge export market for these
crops
and it just goes to show that russia's
invasion of ukraine isn't just a limited
regional problem it actually is
impacting in a much broader way there
have been efforts underway to try and
get the um grain and get the crops out
of ukraine give them safe passage to
leave but clearly zelensky is still very
concerned and still issuing this warning
that this just isn't going to work and
the normal amounts of crops simply won't
be able to be exported in the way that
we might hope they are yeah we're all
very concerned uh back to the uh
conservative leadership campaign um
quick thoughts from both of you on on
this it looks like a u-turn of
colossal size here camilla sunak pledges
four percent income tax cut front of the
daily telegraph i mean you know this is
a man who has chance around his
candidate says well we can't afford them
at the moment and uh tax cuts will be
inflationary
yes exactly this has really been seized
on by liz truss's campaign as yet
another u-turn they're accusing rishi
soon after flip-flopping all over the
place when it comes to tax cuts of
course rishi sunak's whole pledge his
whole economic vision is that we can't
possibly cut taxes now because we need
to keep a lid on inflation and he argues
that this latest policy from him about
the income tax break is still consistent
with his vision because he's saying i'll
cut income tax by the end of the next
parliament so once i've got inflation
under control then i'll deal with the
tax breaks um but of course from liz
truss's camp's perspective they're
saying well
your whole the whole point of view is
that you're talking about we shouldn't
have these tax breaks but here you are
now introducing this 11th hour tax break
okay uh just a minute left then
sebastian on that i mean does this smack
of desperation by the sunac camp such a
u-turn
well the thing about this quite odd
announcement is that it's announcing an
income tax cut in 2028 and the whole
thing is predicated on the conservatives
winning the next general election which
will be a fifth election victory which
the party has never done before and i
think most commentators would look at
the polls and say that's going to be an
uphill battle side so it's very much
jammed tomorrow in a promise here and mr
sunak has promised to cut income tax by
1p in 2024 so that would be the only cut
really before the next general election
is due all this would come in a
subsequent parliament and i think a lot
of people will look at this and say this
all seems rather odd because he stood on
a platform of so-called sound money of
tackling inflation before tax cuts and
the last week has announced two major
tax cuts this one and also slashing vat
on energy bills and so it doesn't feel
as if it's all going to plan for mr
sunak at the moment we've got three more
hustings to come and another five weeks
of this lovely contest